we're going to turn now to our
conversation with some big city leaders
who for the first time in history the
four biggest American cities led by
black Mayors and last week before this
California shooting CBS Saturday morning
co-host Michelle Miller sat down with
three of them New York New York's Eric
Adams Karen bass of Los Angeles and
outgoing Houston mayor Sylvester Turner
collectively they lead nearly 20 million
people and they spoke about the greatest
challenges they face and also reflected
on what this history-making moment means
to them
I'm proud that I'm the first but I will
be very excited to not be the last
when former congresswoman Karen bass was
sworn in last month as the first
mayor of Los Angeles it created another
history-making moment Madam mayor
it's time black Mayors are
of the nation's biggest cities
why does you being in that role as an
African-American matter
well it does demonstrate just how far we
have come and when you look at
African-Americans that are running
cities across the country progress has
been made but it hasn't it hasn't been
easy but let me just say it's one thing
to get there right you also have to stay
there Houston Sylvester Turner is
entering his final year as mayor what
lessons
and what pieces of advice would you
offer them yes well number one we have a
strong freshman class
it requires a solid team you can't do it
by yourself we must act because Mayors
have to produce right
and that includes tackling some of the
biggest challenges facing their cities
what's happening at the board I think is
one major issue that everyone is facing
immigration last year roughly 40 000
migrants arrived in New York City many
bus there by the Texas governor it is
overwhelming our infrastructure and our
ability to give care to our taxpaying
residents just over a week ago New York
city mayor Eric Adams traveled to El
Paso Texas
urging the federal government for more
support no cities should be going
through this Congress has an obligation
and the national government has
obligation that brings with the
responsibility of dealing with this
immediate crisis this is a crisis
another crisis plaguing American cities
homelessness bass has declared a state
of emergency a couple of the root
problems in Los Angeles is our inability
to build housing it takes so long
there's so much paperwork in bureaucracy
and red tape and so the point of the
state of emergency was to say we have to
end that
California has recently seen devastating
storms in Houston's mayor is leading
efforts to address the impact of global
warming
why is it such a top priority for you
well you know in the city of Houston
I've faced seven federally declared
disasters in seven years who are the
people who are most impacted they are
the people that are living in our
vulnerable marginal communities because
they find themselves in a constant state
of need and Recovery reflecting on the
life experiences that led them to where
they are today the trio pointed to their
Roots I grew up in the hood I still live
in that hood nobody has to tell me about
what's not there I see it every day but
I'm determined not to be the mayor of
Two Cities and one of Have and Have Nots
I made a commitment at a very young age
that I wanted to devote my life fighting
for social and economic Justice we're
sending a signal where you are it's not
who you are those who are sitting in
jail right now know that your man was
arrested I'm living the life of people
who are going through what I went
through and that's why I can govern to
make sure they don't have to continue to
go through it for CBS mornings I'm
Michelle Miller
you know what I like about that story is
that all three of them seem to be
talking about reflecting on personal
experiences that have helped them get to
where they are I love what mayor Turner
said you know it's one thing to get
there it's another thing to stay there
yeah all these big National American
problems we Face are for them local
problems they've got to solve them
they're of the people said I grew up in
the hood and I'm still in the hood
that's for sure